oh hello I had welcome to this video
plane and this is alliance or alias
probably alias right so have a name I
haven't seen it all yeah yeah I played
the sky earlier earlier means like you
know weeks ago days ago whatever plus 1
i've got again sir displaying them old
Indian k takes on before don't see that
too often it's usually for to just lead
to a position where black is suffering
from the lack of space quite a bit okay
says wow black has no play years sir the
problem is relatively passive
there are somewhat similar positions
from the Kings Indian but they are black
at least has been cat out and this is
not the case here it's just them yeah
less actively comparison yeah that's an
interesting question do I want to trade
or not
yeah it's probably not bad to trade but
i was thinking might be one could be
interesting let's do that it's a bit
unconventional but keeping the pieces on
the board is an interesting play
it cannot easily play any of his pawns
like c 5 t 5 p-5 it has to stay passive
um still ok I understand that man I
don't be one is not not ideal okay he's
probably shooting from 97 or something
like that or then I have night f5 so
it's no he still does it okay night at
five can I not just take stuff then I
don't get it says some night be two at
the end or I don't I don't I don't see
our camp Louisville we'll see what
happens it takes everything no I fc5 all
the time it's no big point I think he
just blunt at the pawn more or less
okay so love to play a for him but naija
voice is coming age three know he might
take that even should not be shipped e4
is also wrong um let's let's focus see I
can get rid of that they probably won't
take him away he did take
this way i'm also unpinning on the D
file okay where to put the nite nite c4
is the most obvious choice for potential
might be six well the night there isn't
really well placed so this I should yeah
I'm not sure about it okay
let's get rid of that if he goes back a
group t2
Queen d1 he wants to play Quigley one so
I should do this I guess
Crean 88 probably
to try to invade on the a foul no way
this one okay he wants to go 21 Queen f6
g3 know then I have the ship t form okay
I know this is not rocket is actually
rather clear ok so i can go g3 shouldn't
take too long here oh i forgot about
Queen he could have played Queen 83 not
the end of the world but he could have
done that 95 hmm I'm not playing this
well technically
not playing this whale at all
so don't think I screw it up but I was
coming from a really completely winning
position and now this is not looking
that clear that's a double attack though
night and rook
okay what should it should be good
No
check
black resigns it didn't play that well
and he blundered that pawn let's start
with this I think the this opening in
itself the old Indian is usually played
in in a way where black is keeping the
center like we see six or a no Bishop f8
this kind of position and taking us
quite unusual because it is believed
that black doesn't get any counter play
and this is what happened actually in
the game it was very one-sided yeah here
it's it it's not clear I didn't want to
trade an IP one is a bit of a
unconventional decision certainly
playable but still kind of non-standard
n97 this is probably really a blunder
this is difficult now to keep these six
even though the engine just caught
bluntly wants to play this ya know my
okay this isn't this is probably what I
do why did somewhat better but it's not
nothing decisive yet but he gave away
their porn and here I should win without
any big issues but I really didn't it
was so it was still tricky 24 is the the
engine move well quite good okay and
this is wrong the computer wants to do
this I don't quite get the point I
because well my rope here if I move my
rock it will take the 60 i would have to
take rook takes Bishop f4 and this isn't
cleared all i have to do up the exchange
so that was a mistake then Knight c3 but
this was also wrong yeah yeah I've got
everything under control and should win
easily but I didn't at least it didn't
feel
like that yeah g3 is probably not good
Bishop no look a 2 is the strongest AHA
and Bishop the tool to prevent Queen
Queen entries hmm you know it must be
very good and this is a very bad piece
on evade slow i came i did not see 95
years so there whoops ok I'm back I was
the doorbell yeah you should have played
95 here like this and this is mrs.
sighing convenient even though this is
still somewhat better for wide I mean
I'm blundering this is bag him here
black still struggles it's just a pretty
bad piece and I have this idea him ok
and now everything is relatively
speaking back back in order and it
branded Bishop deform yeah it happens it
happens ok thanks for watching